okay it's the height of the morning rush
hour here in downtown nuke
i am standing at one of only two traffic
lights in the entire city there's
this one here and then of course there's
that one
down there you've got number one
and then you've got number two that
pretty much explains it here in downtown
new because you can see
traffic pretty heavy here comes schluten
schluten is uh always coming through in
his volkswagen
and schluten's off he always drives by
there goes glock
glock just went by gluck is in a big
hurry this morning you know gluck he's
got to build that
birdhouse back to you conan this is fun
it's the only member of the paparazzi
here in all of greenland
he's never had anybody to shoot a
photograph
of and finally he's got something to do
my name is kate blanchett i'm an actress
[Applause]
thank you next it was time to take my
offer to buy greenland to the government
oh hello hello miss o'brien how are you
as you know our president trump would
like to
purchase greenland and make it part of
the united states
i am here to facilitate the negotiation
uh tell me how do we make this happen uh
if anybody is to
sell greenland it's greenlandis and
greenland not denmark
so i thank you very much for coming to
the right place at least
the second part of it we haven't
advertised the property on any listings
yet
i uh i did take care of that this
morning i went to the local real estate
office here in nook
our president has made a serious offer
on this country
one trillion dollars is the number we're
talking about the commission
is six percent i will split it with you
it's 30 billion for you
30 billion for me okay you don't have to
make another sale this year
[Applause]
[Music]
as a member of parliament yes you do
have power you do have the ability
to make things happen and i'm prepared
right now
to hand over this starbucks
ball is coming in the pumpkin spice
latte mocha will be available
i'd also like to show you i'm serious
i've brought a special gift
this is 120 000 u.s
dollars this is not my money
i don't want to tell you where i got
this money okay
let's just say i borrowed it from some
very bad people
and you did of course pay taxes
importing it to greenland
i took this into the country illegally i
put myself in great jeopardy
i'm going to leave this here for you i
would like the suitcase back
because this is how i got my underwear
into
do we have a deal i know this is harder
than i thought it was going to work
this is marlene rasmussen and
uh she is a member of parliament
and you are 24. that's incredible
so young to have seized power good for
you
you are the aoc of greenland
that's very cool what would you like to
do for greenland
get the youth freelanders care
more about politics it's an issue too in
the united states is getting young
people
involved in politics i love your office
by the way
thank you i think you could use a little
more stuff in here you thinking about
that
would you like a picture of me in here
you just said no immediately i mean i
have one right here you could get this
framed and it could be in your office
you just you don't want this
i like the blue color but you like the
blue card but you don't like my face
i've never that's the most insulting
thing anyone's ever said to me
look please here
i will give you this money you hang
again
my picture in your office
hey this is kim how you doing kim all
good you live here in uh nuke
well i'm born and raised up in sicily
which is right
and now we're from here okay plane oh we
don't have roads between the
the cities here i've noticed that
there's no roads between the cities the
only way you can get from one place to
the other is in a plane right yeah
exactly how come they don't build a road
going from one place
well it's the arctic like arnold
schwarzenegger says it's the optic
yeah yeah that was a pretty good arnold
schwarzenegger oh yeah
yeah i've been learning that for a long
time yeah actually yours
is almost too uh audible you know what i
mean you gotta mess it up even more
dude get to the chopper
[Applause]
no no no no no
what do you do kim well i'm an artist i
carve
walrus tusk and all that stuff which my
grandfather catches
oh wow that's so cool you've probably
read in the news that president trump is
interested in buying greenland
what do you think of that i'm getting a
vibe that most people are happy the way
things are
yeah they are yes we don't have wars we
don't have like
huge politician issues with with the
other
rights of the world right you're just a
happy guy carving some walrus type yeah
yeah
right you want to meet later on that
little red wine curve some more
restaurants well it depends on my wife
she'll kill you or something like that
she knows how to handle
weapons oh your wife is good with
weapons oh yeah
yeah well i proposed to her when she
shot her first moss box
who proposed to your wife when she
killed her first muscots
yeah exactly and you said on my knees
on your knees will you marry me yeah i
got a picture of it somewhere at home
[Music]
you made the ring was it made out of
walrus dust boom
so you knew it was love when she killed
the mustache
more than love that's where you'll find
out more than love
right i didn't know there was more than
life exactly
i felt that way when my wife knew our
netflix signing code
[Laughter]
that's that's the american equivalent
that's when i knew this was the woman
for me
you know so in a way you know you and i
are the same guy
aren't we i don't know
sure why not do you think i could make
it here in this country you know do the
team man enough to you
yeah you can do it well this is exciting
uh three high school students just
approached me and they say that they
would uh like to interview me for the
school paper
yeah and uh discuss this issue of trump
buying greenland is that correct
gentlemen yes
and uh your names are liam austin cosden
and neues
i'm having a hard time with names here
so i'm going to call you schluten duden
and luden
okay true dude uh luden schnood and dude
i just switched them interchangeably
you can call me styby uh let's begin
what are your questions
do you think that it's disrespectful
that trump comes with this offer to buy
greenland
it's never disrespectful he is a real
estate genius
this man managed to open casinos in a
very profitable area
where people love to gamble and they
failed that's very hard to do
this man knows what he's doing okay i
don't like most of trump's ideas
i think this one might be a good one i
love greenland we should have greenland
wouldn't you like to have mcdonald's
would you like mcdonald's okay would you
like arby's i would
you shouldn't have arbi's
i'm sorry arby's i don't think trump's
being disrespectful all he's saying is i
want to buy your country
if i came to you right now and said hey
i love your hat i want to buy it are you
insulted
uh no no you're not see i see you
yeah yeah yes you don't mind i'd like to
make a gift to you
i'd like to change the hat you're
wearing now for this hat
make america greenland